But even as the
former president
has defended himself in this case, he's
taking swings
at the special counsel
overseeing separate
federal investigations into him
because according to multiple sources
who've spoken
with CNN, it's the probe into the former
president's potential mishandling
of classified documents
that particularly concerns
his inner circle.
My next guests understand
better than most
why we now
have a Presidential Records Act,
which was enacted
after the Watergate scandal.
Journalist Carl Bernstein
is the author
of Chasing History Kid
in the NEWSROOM,
and CNN contributor John
Dean, former White House counsel
to Richard Nixon.
So, Carl,
what does it say to you
that among other laws,
the Presidential Records Act is looming
so large
over the former president's legal fate?
Well, it has all along,
because, among other things,
the president
of the United States announced
he was leaving.
The presidency seems to have directed
the illegal movement
of these documents at Mar a Lago.
But I want to take
a little bit of an issue
in the following way with what you said.
His lawyers
may think that
this is the primary vulnerability,
but in fact, here's three
locomotives bearing down on him.
Former President Trump legally
and probably the most serious
is the January six insurrection
that the special counsel is looking at.
And that investigation is premised
on the huge volumes of fact
about the insurrection,
about Trump's role
in Seditious Lee
trying to stop the peaceful transfer
of power
to the next president
of the United States.
That case itself,
there is a record like the Senate
Watergate Committee
developed
a record that led to the impeachment
and the likely
conviction in the Senate
and eventual resignation
of Richard Nixon.
The January six committee has established
almost a slam dunk record
that is so damning in terms of Trump's
legal vulnerability
that that's really the ones
that the special counsel
is investigating it.
That's really
the ones that most of
the lawyers
I talk to
think is really potentially fatal
for Trump.
John, as a former White House counsel,
how big a deal of it
deal is it that the former
president's own lawyer is being compelled
to testify in the documents case?
It's a big deal
because,
first of all, lawyers
are pretty good witnesses,
which is something that's painful
when they're testifying against you.
And the fact that his privilege didn't
hold and a judge found
at least a prima fascia basis
that there was a criminal act
being portrayed between the two of them,
either
unknowingly by Trump on the lawyer
or maybe the lawyer was involved.
We don't think so at this point.
We don't know.
So this is a problem for him.
And the documents case,
I think, is very serious
because they're looking for
obstruction of justice and they've
got probable cause to get a subpoena
to go in.
Tamara Lago And see these documents,
if you will.
And that's a case that is shown
a judge already
that there's a case there,
criminal activity of some sort.
So that's why I think they're worried.
And Jack Smith is you talked about
I mean, he's not just investigating
the documents case,
also the efforts
to overturn the January six
or the evidence overturn
the election on January six.
He subpoenaed
a number of people
in the former president's inner circle,
former White House chief of staff
Mark Meadows, former
vice President Mike Pence.
Their testimony is
I mean, especially Meadows, his testimony
is potentially explosive
as well as are the same
lawyers that we're talking about
in the documents case and also
are being compelled
to testify
in the January six insurrection case.
And you also have a grand jury in Georgia
with a very damning series of facts
that shows in a telephone call
that was recorded
that Donald Trump, while
president of the United States,
said to the secretary
of state in Florida, find me 11,000 votes
and the intimidation
of a secretary of state to bring about
faulty election intimidation.
That's the other case.
So these locomotives
are all bearing down on him at once.
But meanwhile,
he and
his lawyers are losing
in their motions, case
after case after case.
The attempt to cite
privilege is
now even the lawyers are being forced
to compelled
and being compelled
to tell what they know
before the special counsel
and his grand jury.
So that's what we saw in New York
this week is just the beginning.
And we're going to see through
the next year is a a whole litany
of terrible corruptive facts
about Donald Trump
and his conduct of office and attempt
to stop the legal transfer of power
to his successor who was duly elected.
This is not about the big lie.
This is about Trump
trying to stage a coup
and stay in office
in a way
that no president of the United States
has refused
to let the orderly transfer of power
take place, as Trump has done.
And the facts are there
through that January six committee.
And, John,
our eye on that, John,
I mean, it's incredible
the the extent to
which the former president
just continues to go after the people
who are investigating him.
Jack Smith,
he called a totally biased
thug on Tuesday night,
obviously going
after the judge in the case in New York,
talking about the judge's
wife, the judge's daughter.
It's true.
He likes to belittle the process.
That's part of it.
He plays politics
and doesn't
follow the rules
that prosecutors
and judges are forced to follow
where they can't respond
to most of these charges he makes.
And it's very difficult for a judge
say this judge warned in New York.
He warned
Trump's lawyers and Trump was right there
listening to it.
But the problem is,
Anderson,
there's really little ways to enforce it.
It's not likely he can bring Trump in
and put him in jail,
particularly for the offenses thus far.
If Trump did something horrendous,
he might. But it's just very remote now.
So judges have great
difficulty enforcing this sort of gag
and keeping people behaving.
Yeah.
John Dean, Carl Bernstein,
I appreciate it. And I thank you.